the agenda is adopted
first time in more than five years the
United Nations security Council took up
the issue of Human Rights abuses in
North Korea the meeting was requested by
the United States Japan and Albania
accusing Pyongyang of overspending on
its nuclear program while millions of
people go hungry and are denied basic
goods and the dprk's repressive
political climate allows the government
to divert resources to weapons
development at the expense of the
welfare of the people in The dprk Who
suffer from severe economic hardship and
malnutrition
North Korea has consistently denied the
accusations but the High Commissioner
for human rights described a system
designed to keep the North Korean leader
Kim Jong-un in power the widespread use
of forced labor including political
prison camps forced use of school
children to collect harvest the
requirement for families to undertake
labor and provide a quota of goods to
the government
and confiscation of wages from overseas
workers all support the military
apparatus of the state and its ability
to build weapons one young man who
escaped described being forced to work
in the fields instead of going to school
and having family members in prison for
not reporting his departure the U.N
estimates there are more than 80
thousand political prisoners in the
country
not a single country defended the
actions of the dprk whose Ambassador
declined to take part in the meeting but
there was debate about whether or not
the security Council whose mandate is
International Peace and security was the
appropriate place to talk about human
rights
North Korea continues to develop nuclear
weapons and missiles in violation of
council resolutions and China argued
that calling the meeting would only
escalate tensions while Russia accused
the U.S of distracting attention from
its own provocative acts
we all know the USA Japan and Korea as
part of the so-called deterrence policy
are continuing military exercises in the
region
more than 50 Nations sided with the
United States in condemning North
Korea's alleged abuses saying its
actions constitute a threat to
International Peace and security they
vowed to keep up the pressure on
Pyongyang Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the
United Nations